the Joe Rogan experience yeah everyone
comes out though old lady came out soon
what yeah exactly that's what I'm
talking my bit that I used to have about
the draw Muhammad contest that they did
in Texas there's a Charlie Hebdo you
know the magazine charlie hebdo's is
magazine in Paris and they did a cartoon
about Muhammad you're not supposed to
draw Muhammad well they killed everyone
that worked at it killed like nine
people they killed police officer it was
a really big issue huge international
issue everybody was in terrified
everybody's like [ __ ] did that have
something to do with South listen listen
no no the New York Times wouldn't draw
the pictures they wouldn't it wouldn't
print the pictures the Los Angeles Times
wouldn't put the pictures Washington
Post wouldn't print the pictures no one
was doing anything then Texas got into
the mix and they decided to have a draw
Mohammed contest
oh-ho instantly within within minutes a
dude showed up in with it with his
friend they started shooting at the
building they were killed almost
instantly and I'm like why because they
were doing a draw
Mohammed contest in Texas I'm like did
you pay attention to anything about
Texas and then I got this whole bit
about how this the the place where there
there's you know that bit about more
tigers in captivity in Texas and all the
wild in the world
what's the bit iris from triggered from
my 2016 special but there's more tigers
in captivity in Texas than all of the
wild of the world that's how crazy Texas
says Texas is Wild West people who just
said we're going right here when they
just stopped all those Kit Carson type
dudes from the [ __ ] Wild West they
just stopped in Texas and they stayed
there there's more Tigers in Texas than
the whole rest of the planet that's
insane
it's insane they're in dudes yards yeah
that's what's insane and I go it all
started with one of the guys got a tiger
the other guys like I didn't know where
your Tigers [ __ ] and he went got two
Tigers and the first guy was like I
ain't about to let this [ __ ] out Tiger
me and he and he opened up Tiger Worlds
and that's literally what it's like down
there dudes have hundreds of Tigers in
their yard that's crazy you can have a
yard and if you have the resources you
can keep those Tigers fed you can have
fences where you have a hundred Tigers
in your yard
Texas is a different animal son but it's
one of the safest places to be it's one
of the
it is violence in Texas just like
there's violence whenever you get large
groups of people yeah but I like people
in Texas they're friendly Dallas I like
Dallas a lot man
they're like Austin I like you I like
everywhere I go in Texas but they're
[ __ ] there they're what I would want
America to be like they're cordial they
hold doors for you they say good morning
they look you in the eye they're smiling
Texas is is um not only the best place
in the United States for me for jujitsu
seminars but also comedy to Texas ooh
Texas is a different animal comedy 200
people show up for seminars it's it's
insane man I did my first CD in Texas
yeah Houston if the laughs Houston is
the best place that's the number-one man
both Dallas and Houston well I don't
know man I love Austin too but
[Applause]